hoy ha empezado la segunda fase del
confinamiento de shanghai la que afecta
a los que viven al oeste del río huangpu
y sin que haya terminado la primera tal
y como estaba previsto a última hora de
ayer muchos de los que viven en el este
recibieron la notificación de que su
encierro se prorrogaría desde 3 a 10
días más es una medida que muchos temían
porque los test han seguido revelando un
número altísimo de contagiados durante
toda la semana hoy han sido más de 4000
y ya se daba por descontado que apenas
cuatro días no serían suficientes para
embridar la pandemia el resultado es que
la mayoría de los 26 millones de
habitantes de shanghai están hoy
encerrados en casa y eso tiene dos
efectos el primero es el económico que
se antoja enorme porque shanghai es el
pulmón financiero de china y el segundo
es la desmoralización
ciudadana porque el primer confinamiento
de shanghai en más de dos años está
agotando la paciencia de muchos en las
redes sociales se agolpan las críticas
por la incapacidad del gobierno local
para hacerles llegar víveres y otros
elementales las autoridades
recientemente reconocieron que no se
habían preparado lo suficiente y
pidieron disculpas y prometieron que
mejorarán la logística en los próximos
días